a source confirms to ET laura Prepon is  engaged to Ben Foster it's fantastic and  I'm very excited it's a wonderful the  two made their first red carpet  appearance as a couple at the girl on  the train premiere Tuesday night in New  York and it was also the debut of that  rock on Laura's ring finger yeah I mean  it's amazing Laura is starring opposite  Emily Blunt in the new flick based on  the best-selling novel we're actually  pretty accurate - the book is like you  know orange we really like kind of  splinter off into you know different  worlds but but yeah I mean it's amazing  it's great to be part of it was on the  list for an insane amount of time it's a  beautiful book and I think that I think  that we do that justice with the movie  Foster was previously engaged to Robin  right before ending their relationship  in August 2015